germany's three candidates to replace
angela merkel as chancellor have clashed
in their second tv debate front-runner
olaf schultz of the social democrats was
hoping to extend his lead in the polls
as he faced a grilling from his
conservative rival amen lascit third
place candidate annalina balbach of the
greens tried to make up lost ground
voters in germany's go to the polls to
choose a new parliament on september
26th
let's check in on those snap polls now
that were taken just after the debate
around 20 percent uh of respondents said
here that conservative candidate amin la
should perform best in the debate
meanwhile over 30 percent said schultz
was actually the most convincing making
him the winner among the three uh the
greens candidate annalina berbock
performed only marginally better than
her conservative rival amin lashit but
that put on angela merkel's party at the
losing end of this tv debate that being
said 21 think that all of the candidates
performed equally well in this debate
and we have our political correspondence
brunch with us to put this all into
context for us you watched the debate so
who do you think came out on top here
one has to say that in the end it was
olaf schultz who who did best in this
but uh one has to add that uh what
annalina barbour the green candidate did
uh was also quite impressive she
uh is not under the same sort of
pressure as the other two because it's
clear that she's not going to be the
winner in this election she's not going
to be chancellor she has a lot more room
to maneuver and she came across a lot
fresher a lot more decisive in her
answers
so i think while olaf schultz was
certainly the convincing candidate for
the majority of the viewers um i think
annalina babbok did very well as well
what about angela merkel's party the cdu
their candidate amin lashed he really
needed to get a boost in this debate did
he get that
what he's done in recent days is he's
become a lot more aggressive and there
were quite a number of scenes in this
debate where he especially attacked the
social democrat olaf schultz um there
were some quite um
harsh
exchanges between the two of them but
for i mean luscious this comes across as
a little bit artificial he's actually a
very nice guy and uh where he started
his campaign a couple of months ago
on the basis of being a nice guy of not
provoking uh uh
any of the other candidates of simply
waiting and seeing and that has turned
out to be the wrong strategy so now he's
trying to put up this fight
and he's doing that according a kind of
a according to a kind of script but it
comes across a little bit artificial
what were the biggest issues that they
discussed in this debate it was a very
uh domestically focused debate there
were issues such as pensions healthcare
housing industrial policy that sort of
thing
for foreign viewers there wasn't really
much in it there was some debate about
germany's role in nato that has to do
with the socialist left party which
criticizes nato very strongly and might
be a possible coalition partner for the
social democrats there was also some
mention for the need for foreign workers
or foreign employees to come into
germany experts in various fields
because germany really does need them i
think all candidates agree that that is
the case you mentioned that it's
becoming pretty clear that the greens
candidate analyst that she's likely not
going to be chancellor but how what are
the chances for the greens to do well in
this election oh they're definitely
going to do well they're not going to
come out as the strongest party which
seemed possible a couple of months ago
but they're still going to probably
double the amount of votes that they had
during the last election four years ago
and that makes them a very strong
contender for any government that is
going to be formed it's very likely that
the greens will be part of the next
government so that position is a very
strong one and the fact that they are so
strong on the climate issues on the
climate policy
will mean i think that that will play a
major role in whatever government we're
going to get after after this election
the question is which government that
will be i know there are a lot of
coalition possibilities but
if you just give us an overview what
looks most likely at the moment well
this is what's very new in german
politics there's basically
three parties three major parties that
are almost
at a similar level the ones that were
participating in this debate but there
are two or three other smaller parties
that could also be part of a coalition
probably are necessary for a coalition
the free democrats the business friendly
party and the socialist left party that
i mentioned amongst them um so the
permutations are really really
complicated and
it's going to be very important who's
going to be the strongest candidate
because the person who wins whose party
wins the most votes can take the
initiative in forming a coalition so if
the social democrats do that that's
going to be a very different way of
seeing a new government than if the
conservatives were to win
our political correspondent hans brown
thanks for your analysis